(dépucelage auditif)
C'est l'heure d'une compilation de jeux
Allez la machine est lancée, c'est parti pour le premier jeu
(sifflet d'un train à vapeur)
Eh franchement...
J'ai gardé tous les accessoires
et tous les jours je suis là avec ça
Je souffle
Et hop je fais la meuh (boîte à meuh)
Putain je suis un gamin je n'aurais jamais dû acheter tout ça
ça va rester sur mon bureau jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
ALORS !
On commence avec un jeu qui s'appelle "Hide The Porn" : "Cacher le Porno"
Ne me jugez pas, voilà ça juge direct !
C'est un problème auquel chaque homme a fait face
Bah en vrai c'est plus nos parents je pense qui ont fait face à ce problème
Tu sais
Où ils achetaient des magazines là avec des filles nues
aujourd'hui les jeunes vont sur les sites pornographiques
Je parle comme si j'étais vieux (lol)
Mais à l'époque il fallait vraiment trouver toute trace
de de de
Magazines
Et les cacher avant que ta mère arrive dans ta chambre
Sinon elle te mettait une vilaine fessée
Des tissus utilisés le mec, il met ça par terre
Non mais attend c'est sérieux ?
Mais ça c'est un truc pour se laver les mains
C'est bon il y a rien ?
Mais il y a rien !
Mais la meuf a vu quoi j'ai pas compris là !
J'ai retiré les magazines, j'ai retiré les tissus !
Ah l'historique !
AAAAH ça !
ça c'est problème d'aujourd'hui ça !
Normalement il y a rien
Si ma mère me gueule dessus c'est juste qu'elle aime être méchante
C'est bon
Mais elle arrive quand même en gueulant !
Quoi qu'il arrive !
J'ai gagné mais elle est quand même arrivé en gueulant
TRÈS BIEN...
Oh mais mec nan mec !
non mais là
n'importe quoi...
'Tain le mec, on dirait c'est un fleuve quoi
Quand hein...
(malaiseTV)
Vas-y normalement j'ai tout retiré, il reste des magazines vite fait
Ahh là-bas je les ai vu !
C'est bon ?!
Normalement il y a plus rien
Et elle arrive encore en gueulant !
Mais maman mais tu peux venir et me parler tranquillement !
On peut avoir une amitié mère-fils qui est bien mieux qu-
Oh merde putain, j'ai que 10 secondes !?
C'est mort...
C'est mort !
C'est bon j'avais tout retiré
Oh la vache !!
Oh mais mec... mais non mais gros le mec il abuse quoi..
Attend le mec, c'est quoi cet enfant ? C'est pour ça qu'elle arrive tout le temps en gueulant
Le mec passe sa journée dans sa chambre à se masturber ou quoi ?
T'as déjà vu ça toi ?
Le mec a 20 tâches dans sa chambre, 18 magazines
On dirait qu'il a invité ses potes à se masturber avec lui quoi...
Oh putain, il reste deux trucs c'est limite
C'est bon ça passe !
Oh il restait une chaussette !
(moment de réflexion)
En quoi une chaussette ça me fait perdre ?
Non nooooooon !
Noooon je refuse de NOOON !
Bon ce qui faut retenir de ce jeu finalement c'est quoi ?
C'est que cet enfant a un gros problème mental, c'est pour ça que sa mère arrive tout le temps en gueulant dans sa chambre
Elle est jamais heureuse de le voir
Parce que son fils passe ses journées à se masturber et à ne rien faire
Il va pas à l'école, il travaille pas, il fait rien
Du coup ce que j'aimerai c'est qu'on passe...
MEUUUUH...
au jeu suivant
(la boîte continue de faire meuh sans arrêt xD)
Non c'est bon cest bon c'est bon C'EST BON
(elle ne s'arrête pas...)
(musique de western)
Savez-vous qui je suis ?
SQUEEZIEAST WOOD est de retour
avec...
WTF mec !
Attend c'est barbichette de Maxence là ?
de Floran Pagnot qui ahaha !
Putain ! il faut vraiment que je range mon bureau quand je fais un tournage
On est sur "Ricochet Kills"
Et  vous allez voir c'est un peu le même principe que le jeu avec la bouteille là
Je l'avais trop kiffé vous l'avez trop kiffé aussi il était vraiment bien ce jeu
C'est un peu le même principe on a un certain nombre de balles et il faut tuer un certain nombre de personnes avec ces balles
Dit comme ça c'est un peu glauque
Il faut utiliser le rebond
Voilà comme ce qui vient de se passer
Oh eh je gère hein ?
J'ai fais en seulement 3 balles
Alors que j'avais 5 balles à la base
Parce qu'on m'appelle... (musique de western)
J'en ai marre de dire ce pseudo nul
Clac clac okay là on va en avoir 5
(Musique de Western)
FACILE
Là on va en avoir 4
(Encore une musique de Western...)
EASY
Là on va en avoir...
euh...bah un seul
Et il me reste 4 balles mais on est pépèèèère !!
3 pardon
J'avais mal fait mes calculs
Je mise sur 5 personnes..
(Il a raté mdr)
Très bien
J'ai rien parié je m'en bas les couilles
Eh ouais gamin EH OUAIS GAMIN !
EASY
A aucun moment je n'ai paniqué
WHOO !!
Whoo !
D'où il y a autant de gens à tuer là ?
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ?
Ils ont pas mis de pouce bleu sur mes vidéos
Très bien
(meurtre de masse)
*choc*
Whooo !
Eh tout ce que j'ai flingué et j'ai même pas fait exprès
Et là il m'en reste deux ah ben il y a un mec là-bas allez hop
voilà
On en parle pluuus !
Et là ils sont morts du coup ?
ou ils sont juste paraplégiques ?
Genre si je fais ça est ce que ça tue les mecs en bas ou pas ?
Ouais !
HOP !
EEEET
Et voilà et VOILÀ !
J'ai même pas d'arguments
(musique western suspens)
ça dégage..
(second massacre)
(non ce n'est pas du lubrifiant)
Ouais quand les gens quand ilsfont un truc stylés ils se mettent du gel hydroalcoolique sur les mains derrière
OK
OKAY (montée d'adrénaline)
OKAAY (commence à devenir fou)
(je vais arrêter de dénombrer, okay ?)
ça c'est très bien joué gamin
Je pense qu'ici en faisant ça
OOOoooh !
(coup de klaxon à air comprimé)
Incroyable
Ce level est dur !
ça commence à me prendre un peu la tête
Ah parce que mon chapeau n'était pas droit, putain
Bah oui !
Ok... (encore)
Okay
Yep
And the last one
(nope)
Adios amigos hijo de puta !
oh nan c'est quoi ce level là ?
Oh nan les mecs ils abusent là !
Eh là ils poussent le bouchon un peu quand même je trouve
Bon écoute-moi bien hijo de puta ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va compter jusqu'à 6 et tout le monde va mourir
(musique western le retour)
UNO
DOS
(TRES ? xD)
TRES
CUATRO
CINCO
Y para terminarlo
SEIS
(musique western ambiance épique)
QUOI ?!
Mais je l'ai pas vu lui il fait quoi là-bas le mec ?!
y SIETE
(le mec sent le skill monter en lui ^^)
(coup de klaxon (raté))
(Bruh !)
Nous sommes maintenant sur "Skribble.io"
Oui c'est jeu .io oui
mais il est très très cool vous allez voir c'est une sorte de "Pictionnary"
Alors on va s'appeler "Jean-Michel"
c'est parti et là on arrive dans une chambre et chacun notre tour on va choisir un mot comme Gérald est en train de faire actuellement
Ensuite il va nous le dessiner et nous on va devoir trouver ce que c'est
le problème c'est que le site est en anglais donc je pense que ça va être la merde
C'est jaune c'est le soleil
(rire aspiré)
C'est ça ! Ouuuuiii !
et jean-michel on était 3ème à deviner mon gars
On est présent ou pas ?
dans le game ?
"trapdoor" choisit un mot
Vas-y trapdoor
(imcompréhension)
WTF (mdr)
C'est quoi ça ? c'est une plante ?
C'est un artichaut, ARTICHAUT !
Salade
Laitue
MAIS C'EST QUOI ?!
Chou-fleur
Ouais mais c'est en anglais !
Comment on dit ?
"Cauliflower"
C'est un chou-fleur
(faute d'orthographe lol)
Cauli...
Colisée
C'était quoi ?!
Le mot était "cauliflower"
OH NAN !!
OH NAAAAAAAAAAAAN (voix féminine)
(transition bruit aiguë klaxon détraqué)
Oh nan j'ai mal orthographié je suis tellement une merde
(musique triste au piano)
OK c'est à nous de choisir
Entre "peau", "midnight" ou un "lézard"
(pense à quelque chose de con)
UN LEZARD !
(Musique épique qui ne colle pas avec le jeu ^^)
Ils ont (presque) tous deviné mon lézaaaard !
Eh je suis en train de faire des écailles
démerdez-vous bande de salopes
"Je suis perdu" (lol)
(rire de bâtard machiavélique)
DEMERDEZ-VOUS !
Critique pas mes dessins comme ça "Jurnee"
Tu peux pas te permettre de me critiquer parce que moi je dessine pas toute la...
JURNEE (lol)
(bruit de klaxon saccadé)
Suivant.
Un peigne
Un peigne c'est un peigne
Alors je crois qu'il y a des gens qui dessine pire que moi
mais mille fois
C'est quoi ça (za ?) ?
Et mon lézard à côté mon gars mais c-c'est la Joconde
"fork"
Une fourchette
Donc ça pour toi c'est une fourchette ça ?
Eh ben mec je suis désolé de t'anoncer que depuis que t'es tout petit tu manges en réalité avec un PEIGNE !
c'est pas grave tu manges tes putains de pellicules mon gars
OK à nouuuuf...
Qu'est ce qu'on va leur faire deviner à ces petits cons ?
On va finir sur un truc magnifique
Un microphone !!
(l'inspiration lui vient à l'esprit)
C'est parti
(retour musique épique)
(aucun ne trouve XD)
C'est un mec qui parle dans un micro là !!
Bon je vais les aider
ALLEZ !!
Il y en a qu'un qu'a trouvé !
AHAH
Il parle dans un micro, c'est ça que j'ai dessiné !
FAITES PAS GENRE !
Oh nan Jurnee il a quitté carrément !
Ahhhhh...(il a perdu son souffle ^^)
C'est un mec qui parle dans un mircophone mais putaiinn !
C''est un microoo...
C'est un micro.
C'était un micro trapdoor a trouvé
"désolé si vous êtes mauvais"
(doight d'honeur furtif)
Eh bien voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette petite compilation de jeux
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
Ben moi j'ai bien aimé les jeux d'aujourd'hui étaient sympa, les liens sont dans la description si vous voulez y faire un tour
Notamment "Scribble.io" en plus ça vous fera travailler votre anglais
Allez à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo portez-vous bien et surtout n'oubliez pas...
PEACE ! (voix sortie du klaxon)
Oh !
Merci d'avoir suivi les sous-titres j'ai passé pas mal de temps à les faire et surtout c'est la première fois donc si éventuellement il y a des petits détails à changer n'hésitez pas à me le dire ^^, merci !
EDIT : yo, je ne suis pas la créatrice des sous-titres mais j'ai corrigé quelques petites erreurs de conjugaison et de compréhension qui me titillaient :) ~ M